I'm going to start with an individual
question for you actually uh if someone
has never seen anything you've done
before what is the first thing you want
them watching and why oh wow that's
interesting I had to go with Bandit I'm
going to go with me good answer
um listen I've been very blessed you
know obviously I've been blessed you
know you know my whole life getting
great opportunities this was one of
those and I'm not saying it's just
because you're here this was a true gift
I was in Pensacola uh you know promoting
my helping my wife promote her book when
I get the call three days before I'm
supposed to shoot this an offer to do
this film and I'm going what this is
crazy and I read it right away
immediately of course I say yes I hop on
a plane from there two days later we're
shooting and it it turned into one of
the most incredible blessings
um the entire project this man did The
Impossible shooting this film in 21 days
with this incredible cast but I think
for me for to tell audiences if there's
something to watch me this one because
the experience was so free in the sense
that there was not there was no time to
prepare we had to work with the
constraints that we had
um that kind of frees you up as an actor
in a weird in a weird way because you go
well look I don't have this this
Albatross of like I've got to do so much
homework the homework I can do is is
defined by the time I have and so I
think subsequently between the way you
directed and and the constraints of what
we had it was one of for me one of the
most freeing performances and to me if
you have that environment as an actor
that that's kind of a gift to the actor
and hopefully to the audience I I
definitely actually wanted to talk to
you about that aspect is that you I am
very impressed with what you pulled off
with the limited resources and time that
you had what was the thing that you were
most scared about before filming began
about actually being able to do it with
the limitations that were in front of
you yeah I mean the big thing was trying
to recreate Canada and Georgia that was
sort of the thing that terrified me
luckily Alicia had lived in Ottawa she
kind of came on like the locations like
yeah this Victorian architecture I think
this will work for the Glebe for our
house
um no I mean just just knowing that this
should have been a 35-day shoot at a
certain budget level in Canada and then
becoming half the amount of time in
Georgia was incredibly scary but I had
the most incredible cast my art team was
amazing trying to recreate you know
Canada and all I did was just Prep Prep
and learn everything off by heart so
that there was just no way I could screw
it up right I would imagine that also uh
impacts how many takes you have on set
how many locations you have to hit in a
day yeah all of that stuff yeah and we
had 95 locations in the film in 200
scenes so the the original cut was three
hours long for 21 days which was sort of
like a haha to the producers we did it
yeah I know three hours but yes I know
and this man knew every c number so I
would talk about I would ask about a
question in a certain scene he goes oh
scene 157 he literally knew every scene
by another that's how much prep this man
did but but seriously that's why the
movie looks as good as it does the fact
of with the limitations is because you
have to you can't have even a half an
afternoon wasted everything has to be on
screen no no no and we ended up doing uh
having to do some second unit stuff I
know so Nestor as an amazing TV director
I said to him listen this movie we're
never going to finish we're splintering
off into three units now I'm going to be
downstairs we had this Old Courthouse
that had like 10 sets in it so I'd be
downstairs directing Josh and Alicia
they'd call cut and the walk say Alan's
coming up to the second unit and
nestor's kind of setting everything up I
call Action cut Allen's running to the
next unit but Nestor essentially took
over all of that well I mean there was
no given the time we didn't have a
choice yeah we had to we had to sort of
divide and conquer it at some point so
so my storyline was somewhat contained
with with swen so I we could do that but
this man was running not no joke between
three sets it went yeah it was insane uh
one of the things I personally anytime
I've worn 80s clothing it makes me crazy
I hate it and I'm just curious what it
was like for you and for everyone else
because 80s clothing is terrible
especially in Georgia humidity yeah and
that yeah that leather jacket didn't it
wasn't very forgiving and the dead heat
of Georgia and Thomasville and Valdosta
you know that was and the humidity was
lovely
um yeah the sweaters are great you know
Josh's flannel sweaters oh those are I
know I saw that in the trailers like I
forgot about that sweater amazing yeah
the 80s man the Merry-Go-Round sweaters
those those are the days
um but I had the best laugh my wardrobe
fitting was the first meeting I had
after actually even before I met you it
was wardrobe and just going oh my God
this has taken me way back it's a good
reason we got rid of these clothes but
uh I I gotta tell you it was fun
whenever you get to wear something like
that as an actor already you're you've
it's almost like it's a gift to an actor
because you're already developing a
character you know it's almost like a
stage actor the first thing they want to
wear is a character's shoes to see see
how they walk you know and it's it's no
different with clothing one of the
things about this film is you can't
believe it's true you know most bank
robbers are lucky to rob a few Banks
once you crack 50 it's it's just such
it's Preposterous but yet it's true can
you sort of talk about that aspect of
the story yeah well the sheer volume I
mean that's what hooked me right from
the get-go because I'd heard the moniker
flying Bandit but I didn't know the
extent to which he had actually pulled
off all of these crimes and the way the
flare and the panat like how he did all
of that it sucked me right in and I knew
that after reading the book I was nobody
is gonna like when we screen to First
Cut someone said he just paid a homeless
guy for his health card that would never
happen I'm like right no it happened and
so that's why we ended up putting those
sort of captions on screen because
people would be like taken out of the
film there's no way this actually
happened all of it did even the pizza
ordering the pizza at the police station
after being arrested it was it was
insane is there anything you want to ask
yeah truth is Stranger Than Fiction it
really is but you're right I'm so glad
you did put those things not only are
they funny but but you're right you
would question that um I yeah that was
that's part of the joy the part of the
ride of this they said it is so
unbelievable and yet it isn't it it
actually happened and and few few of
these films are getting made these these
incredibly uh beautiful character-driven
true stories you know uh that have
elements of action and credit to you
brother and the investors to take a
chance on this one uh last question an
individual for each of you um what's
going on with this driver TV series is
that is that happening I'm waiting on
the studio to call me after I did
Uncharted I was very blessed to be in a
position to get the rights to a lot of
video games people trusted mean sort of
what I pulled off with Fillion and you
know everything is sort of an initiative
these days all the studios you know turn
around development how I'm always
waiting on a call so I'm ready to go I'm
also very curious about Shogun
um oh yeah yeah and so what can you
tease about that because the project
seems very cool it's an incredible
project we shot at in Vancouver you know
uh which doubled for for Japan and uh I
mean extraordinary production value I
mean it was just unbelievable they built
three villages in Vancouver it's it's
you know and they really spared no
expense in terms of you know the details
and and trying to really replicate uh
the the period
um there's not much I can say uh all a
beard oh I did I did have to grow this
nasty beard and uh and do some stuff to
my head that you know I later later paid
for but uh but uh but so much fun to
dive into that kind of character work I
love I love disappearing into roles like
that
um I think it comes out I believe 2023
so it'll be next year sometime next year
but I'm looking forward to seeing yeah
the cut as much as anyone it was
extraordinary that the production was
was like nothing I've ever seen cannot
wait congrats thank you you guys have a
fantastic afternoon thank you